[Music]
previously on grave hoppers show where
we here at GameSpot put permadeath in
every game gonna go for the Hylian
Shield maybe Gannon so you have to ferry
is pretty good in food weapons are good
I'm looking better than I thought
yeah yeah this might be suicide Jesus
but stall it yet again you've screwed us
oh yeah I brought a friend called
spacious you little punk ass what's
doing put your dumb head on let's go
drew Gannon I guess I'm just that good
yeah let's go dig in
[Music]
oh I did I lost all my Perry's I'm just
doing this because I'm pissed off damn
it
the last photo of Linc
come what may the last episode yeah wait
so if you don't do the divine beasts who
fight these guys first oh I didn't know
that
yeah oh yeah one down
Jesus Oh doing good
well I mean this place oh god this one
there's two down
how's that feel and God for the shield
oh I know I didn't have my shield that's
a little cheap welcome to the
Thunderdome I don't remember this whoa
she'll too this is more about dodging
right very valiant effort got through
three of the bosses of the five
technically that was good oh I see what
you mean about the thunder blight yeah
he's kind of a dick hey everyone welcome
back to great hoppers the show where we
here at GameSpot put permadeath in every
game Rob handler what's up that's right
that guy sucks yeah that was you just
saw last episodes highlights finally
done with Zelda but by far the longest
run our objective was to beat Zelda and
as little time as possible I guess but
we wanted a realistic chance so he took
some time get some fairies killing some
Guardians upgrading stasis seven half
hours into breath a while that is that's
the record I think that's right uh-huh
a long shot that's the first game we
made pass an hour am I reading that
correctly you're right you were so close
with Resident Evil or maybe you and Mary
combined I was close let's be honest
that's fair Mary Kay our guest but uh as
always when we die in one game we move
on to the next so today we're just gonna
start off with a brand new game well the
game's not brand new but it's a brand
new to the show
Metal Gear Solid 5 we are starting with
ground zeroes for a few reasons
a because phantom pain has that like
long for our intro that might not be the
most fun thing to watch if I get that
far we'll decide whether we want to show
you that there you go spider-man's
updates though maybe a game later yeah
so right now we're gonna do ground
zeroes playing it out hard the hardest
difficulty possible or whatever we have
available right now I have
few ground rules um okay the chief
primary objective is to rescue Chico and
Paz characters from Peace Walker and I
think that's it from Metal Gear Solid
lore but I'm also going to do a new game
I'm also going to try to rescue every
hostage possible there's a few of them
this can be like two hours so if I die
in this we're moving on to alienate
isolation
yeah but um yeah we had a comment for
someone on YouTube that in regards to
yeah I can read that and I'm gonna
figure out how to start a new game that
was a Kevin Thornton he said love you
guys on the show for suggestions I think
stuff games would be great because of
the tension I very much agree he says
further I'm currently playing through
dishonor two on the hardest difficulty
setting so that would be a great he
thinks that would be great for the show
I totally agree
that is definitely a well suited game
for the show stands as he said stealth
games in general for sure
dishonored either doing metal gear yeah
I accidentally started from a safe side
that's not gonna work I know I gotta
back out man there's so many things to
this menu that I don't remember oh no I
remember how to play a game but then I
wait what is it going on I might just
have to full-on quick restart doesn't
delete the save data I don't think so
because I'm trying to cuz it's just one
of those menus where just continue mmm
feel like it should be easier to start a
new game and I'm just not seeing it but
yeah we'll start the timer right when I
start the game be like a knife I survive
for an hour reminded me yeah what about
beat the game in an hour which again I'm
trying to get all the hostages and I and
I'm trying to definitely do this because
I feel like I have not pulled my weight
on the show yet well I did for a while
and then someone came into the guests
and ruined it
want to make sure I make this count doom
still hurts more than any does hurt you
know just because I was in the flow with
this dude okay here we go he thought
doom hurts of us I was a minute 25
yeah but doom I just like I felt like I
had it even though it's what thirty
minutes in alright here we go
mission elect you sure you want to start
a new mission hell yes thank you okay
cool
okay we only have normal cells plan get
a beat it to plan hard okay but yeah i'm
i got a rescue chico and paws and the
other yeah i don't have hard and the
other hostages so okay it's a pretty
short intro start it right after the
cutscene there's a minor cutscene of him
like infiltrating you got it
we'll go Ground zeroes was what 2015 and
then phantom pain was 16 yeah
phantom pain was 16 ground she was 15
yeah I think you're right feels like a
lot longer ago just because phantom pain
was played so much of it mmm-hmm
so again your plan is just to do the
main mission no no so yeah I'm not I
said I was going a hundred percent it
that's not accurate I'm not gonna get
every like cassette tape but see there
are these prisoners in here okay that
are not part of the Chico and piles of
the main objectives but I'm gonna try to
exfiltrate everybody okay they're just
random NPCs he can get out I think
that's how you get the the hideo kojima
cutscene appearance later where he's
like what took you so long or kept you
waiting huh whenever i'm and he's got
his glasses on okay cool try skip this
or I mean it's pretty short we can watch
it I don't see it if it's short enough
see there's so much dudes I can get out
oh yeah so yeah I practice a little bit
like a week ago to Rhea Metal Gear Solid
controls are usually not the same as
other games so I wanted to reacquaint
myself well suppose gonna say like how
similar to this is it to a phantom pain
oh it's this is just an intro to this
might as well be part of the game it is
right it's it's identical with a smaller
bite-sized world like a short story
version that's Chico
nope pause sorry this is that
skull-faced dude from mana pain
oh [ __ ] I forgot Bowie was in phantom
pain oh yeah that is Chico sorry that's
Chico and he's talking about Paz
and more wargames you're a real man is
he listening to his heartbeat
forgot that really weirds me out don't
take it don't touch it it's horrifying
it's already off to a grim start this is
Cuba
following the events of Peace Walker
fives a prologue to man I forgot I used
to know my own your solid Laura really
well this songs do
and I want to play phantom pain again
yeah
forgot about the cassette tapes you
could just throw on when you're in the
helicopter and stuff it was fun what
Bowie's song was it really good Bowie
song I was in it like maneater was a
while ago I may be that the way we were
playing that game in the office and
talking about it reminded me of like
breath of a while yeah kind of read dead
- yeah it seemed Louisiana Sherman he
found the drifting in Caribbean so
what's the plan before will it
compromise no I've got something else in
mind our friends it's cipher suspect
toss could be a double agent she's being
held for interrogation at a camp on the
southern tip of Cuba black site nice a
slice of American Pie on communist soil
as legal jurisdiction the upcoming
inspection of mother face has to be
connected somehow
the timings to perfect the UN's nuclear
inspection my guess is they're trying to
corroborate cautiously
lucien what if our capabilities gets out
and we'll have the whole world ought to
shut us down
having an American private intelligence
agency involved bad news ciphers the
ones who sent pass to us in the first
place
she knows the true nature
masses of emulate to Sasha if she still
alive
these were on her side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's so cool that this was a freaking
like prequel you know like I said I just
snip it like that's just such a smart
way to like do something
yeah
I play this at least eight times waiting
for phantom pain
I don't think we talk about ground
zeroes enough like I well yeah like you
were saying it's so dope to just have
that bite size like it's an intro to
phantom pain yeah but like in its own
right such a good self-contained like
mission like what are the weather
franchiser game has done something like
that like it's just weird to think like
a like a demo this meeting I don't know
it's a good question I guess if
anybody's gonna do it it's gonna be so
this is right before they go and [ __ ] up
mother base I think until the couch
leads in to Santa Fe
right right and you're rebuilding
another base right but I'm pretty sure
Sochi compiles are peace walker
characters I don't know if you play that
on PSP really good game actually I think
this took place oh you can collect those
too
which is kind of cool this is after
Peace Walker I believe there he is let
me pick it up keeper does he pick up one
of them me yeah maybe
yeah yeah keeper yeah
oh he just got his
all right oh okay we'll send a chopper
from across the Cuban border I'm you
should be better I was thinking of doing
a no-kill run but then I was like if I
get into trouble I still want a fighting
chance and that's why I like phantom
pain because every what you saw at 5:00
and ground zeroes because you do have a
fighting chance as opposed to many other
Metal Gear Solid so we're gonna avoid
killing people with my sorrowful as
often as possible but when necessary
I'll do it because I want to again go
past an hour I'm one of my games all
right oh [ __ ] okay so we're about to go
we're pretty close yeah
you see that new death stranding trailer
yeah
with Troy Baker's character yeah it's
summoning somebody looks like a anus dog
cat yeah
I am oldest [ __ ] in this game yeah
I'm not metal yourself or old yeah I
don't believe I could be butchering this
floor so all right
with that
so I know Chico pauses up here like in
the main face all right
so prone Ardex sweet a bear with me I
did this last week I'm just gonna make
sure I don't like fire rock on on
accident
it's crazy how like you know what normal
it is to have an open world like this
where you're spotting people before you
go in now but like I remember like when
this game did it it was pretty not new
brand new but it was pretty novel like
Far Cry 3 had done it before but this
was like specifically stealth I'm just
gonna make sure I cover all my bases I
think it's just far more crucial right
yeah yeah like Far Cry yeah I can Far
Cry you can always like pick up stealth
again if you screw up yeah it's like
it's like you you mess up it's
monumental dude that's so yeah okay cool
go with my sound pistol wait for the
light to pass
it's the button - there we go right
shoulder
press the action button um I don't want
to waste a dar I think I could just make
sure I mark this dude I think I could
just melee that dude up there your
climate in the tower yeah yeah I'm just
gonna go around
actions triangle a typical
all right so that's off that's good in
case I come back here I don't think I
will for a while but dude there I'm
gonna use this to keep the lay of the
land the hill wait back up yes action oh
yeah actually good point
I shouldn't there we go thank you for
that reminder so they say do you record
for longest headshot see so what he does
it so he would have waken up you're you
were right he would have woken up just
from my melee attack yeah and I would've
been fine I was ranked him for the cows
now I yeah that he's essentially out for
unless I take like something an obscene
amount of time I think he's out and I'll
get more it's not like I have a scarcity
of ammo coming up
now head east to the old prison area
take a good look at the enemy through
your binoculars and you can mark him
marked enemies can be sensed when nearby
even if there's a wall between you and
your attention this house you maintain
situational awareness are there like
scripts in this game that that happened
like well into your play like a jeep
driving by or something or like even
something more intricate like someone
will do something like an hour in like
this doesn't that doesn't get very
intricate as far as yeah timeline of
this cuz you could you I don't know I
keep hearing about you and other people
who play this game all times on end like
oh I mean there are different there are
different like modification modifiers
and all right that's like that that's
one thinking that but yeah the longer
you take like different I mean you could
speedrun it but like diff yeah different
there will be different patrol routes
alright this part always yeah whoops
sorry blinded everybody
wait one enemy was in the air I mean he
hasn't left yeah yeah that's what that
mean Oh
oh you're gonna gonna go for it
not yet he's not really like moving
office he does get to these sand eggs
okay
it
what is heard of Jeep
ASSA truck
ie
shoulda shot this light yikes
thought I had it this gun doesn't have
their range damn flies you should also
aim your weapon better oh another car I
hear that dude yeah he's still asleep
all right good
is that light still on though no the
spotlight he was using
yeah well that that'll be automatically
give you a wave no I just I just don't
want it to be lit up something you could
probably shoot it from up there oh that
one no no no I was talking about the you
probably shoot it I don't even know if I
need to it you're right this one's kind
of
[ __ ] I should wonder if I should get up
there and okay oh that's right there's
like a shakes I was like a binocular
Mike you can pick up audio chatter and
stuff
geez forget if there's a guy in this
little Hut thrower hey do you guys hear
that's what farted no that's dumb he's
gonna turn around see that that damned
[Music]
yeah go for it no cars no cars no cars
no cars oh oh I remember this map now
yeah there's like a little bit mini
prison down here ah what should I hit
him he's in the spotlight though yeah
but if I hit him in the body he'll faint
in the dark but no one's looking at him
right now
no they're not right now but yeah he's
in the light two guys down here if I
remember correctly around the outside
and there's a hole in the back of the
fence that I can go through there's one
market so these none of these are chica
you find out that they're not yeah but
I'm gonna try to get the other prisoners
him I'll wait for him I don't want to
deal with him on the way back up though
I think him now actually if I'm alien
where's that other dude I think he's
buying you could drop yeah it's not
instant if it's not in the head
oh he heard that you saw him I think
that's all right
I don't know where I met
it's good he'll pass out on us a few
seconds oh that's women by instant the
head is instant yeah I could pump a few
more into him come on pass out before
you see the body you'd think he'd be
alarmed right now I got Rankin right
he's down here I gotta get this guy nice
distance oh I thought you saw the by he
didn't know he passed out oh it looked
like it all right okay cool I'm gonna
this place what do I do with these I
hope no one else comes down this is
gonna look real bad
bushes bushes okay so I shot them all so
they're gonna be out for a while gonna
be pretty cautious so bear with me
I could put them in dumpsters maybe
that's her cycle
you guys don't compost and your dare
or at
yeah the Miller cat calves celerity you
gotta wing them one by one
oh it's it's down there and that's one
of the extraction points possible I'll
try not to
you know hurry up screaming any point in
getting all these guys out there just
all over here yeah can't you just like
put them all down and then call it in or
say yeah yeah but I don't know if I yeah
I guess
few more about
[ __ ] that cliff right yeah [ __ ] forgot
one life yeah
I'm sure I'm way I'm already kind of
doing this but I'm debating on whether I
should even do it there's no challenge
to getting all of them now one of the
comments that maybe you could read while
we're doing this sure
a lot of it or just for regarding my
down god sorry we're going to death
commander Jane Shepard said nice try Rob
but thunder flight was way too hard and
you had the longest record survival and
Dave hoppers thank you oh sorry I don't
know I'm sorry I threw him betta hey
says breath a while is easy a [ __ ] who
as Carter getting to him
then actually fighting Ganon that's fair
and sometimes yeah I don't know
everybody talks remember another guy
comes down here I'm kind of just [ __ ]
see what this says oh this is Chico so I
need to go
on unlucky rob Valley never completely
forgot you had a psyches at this point
if not done inside the beast yeah I
totally forgot
[Music]
[ __ ] he's dead he just choked him out
yeah she goes back I got Chico not here
[Music]
I hate it when that happens
that's horrifying Chili's tendon um
okay actually I'll get him out I'll call
in the helo
well that track you'd like him I don't
think so okay I'll do this quick contact
the Chico nice I've been more people now
I hope not I'm just gonna go who's
saying that oh the other dude okay you
don't you can keep playing right the
game doesn't end correct
yeah it won't if unless I get on it get
pause as well sorry shut up you play it
I don't know if there's anyone near him
I think I'm good okay I got a oh god I
thought okay what I keep thinking guys
are gonna come from that way to get this
guy quick get this guy quick get this
guy quick
you know run
please
there's the other
easy on the left
I'm gonna get this guy okay let's be
careful then I remember I think I'm good
behind you I know I took these guys up
like some reason I thought what just
happened there happened behind me as
well oh shut up Miller
I think it's Miller was it Roberta no
revolvers it's he's so good right now
yeah cuz I think I get Miller later no
this is no I don't know like Aslan right
well he helps you in this game yeah
you're not yet
like rivals are your rival you're not
yet enemies is the word I was looking
for all right it gets tough after here
when I have to go toward the base
you can sit in the rain I'll be right
back
I know I love how I put down the enemy
like softer than that actually while I'm
here
I think gun fell on its barrel who's
this handle for maybe my assault rifle
thank you for bearing with me while I
get all these guys out just doing
something new I knew there's a water
there was a reason it would like be a
little bit tougher I forgot these two
came yeah well I guess that happens when
I got Chico but whatever it's not leave
anybody behind
she got shut up you just have nuts
drilled into your Achilles tendon it's
not that bad
nobody's like a bomber how many was this
five right thumb [ __ ] ah we left
chica where's poss sorry what
[Applause]
[Music]
don't so many hell with that
where's the other dude
aha oh no I don't need to put them here
first I forgot to pick them up manually
and put them in the helo but I'll do it
anyway
l1 cut that
intended anything didn't dan 10-10-10
splicing music flight of the valkyries
yeah that was a song right well that I
don't know if that's in it it might be
yeah because I remember people doing the
Apocalypse Now thing where are you
there is oh look at that let's get low
let's get fares
don't worry
didn't she go out first
kids in America man who sold the world
to David Bowie song I was thinking
take on meson there's one more that's
right rebel yell yeah okay [ __ ]
just circle yeah I know but I was I was
like [ __ ] I don't want to try getting me
on yeah
by well those guys are gonna sit here
for a while Oh cuz you did cheat go
first I guess I don't know I'll put them
back in the cave and get them later all
right
going into the base how much time have I
been going good question who's that
truck no it's you're at 23 minutes let's
get serious
most pcs if don't get scared probably
get this now
to get this weapon here
alright guy in the tower gonna see no
he's facing the other way but I can't
remember if there's like dude I've been
playing um not everyone Oh can't you get
in the truck to get in
that's one way to get in yeah [ __ ]
actually another way
alright let's wait and I just hear
someone go
that was him dropping I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure it's not like I'm
dropping Wow I guess I I guess it is a
bullet flying into class pretty good guy
up there I think
I'm not even gonna take a chance gonna
bring back here
I feel so weird leaving a watch tower
dude should I risk going across the road
to get him I think so
I don't even have to go across the road
I'm gonna shoot him from here yeah
that's true oh that flashlight Wow turn
that off I feel like oh there it is
I could take the suppressor off I wanted
to just do the binocular to think it
might be over here alright I'll just
shoot this dude I don't even have to
hide him he'll be already be up there no
I'm not sure now when there's a guy out
there
can I go up here without it yeah I guess
so
oh that was not a guy can do that cannon
pretty sure I need to take that out if I
want to call a helicopter closer to the
base oh really
I think so cool I don't need one oh [ __ ]
yeah
no one weird really there would be a guy
there well there's a guy I do I post
yeah
surprised it's like there'd be a guy
around here yeah what really okay maybe
that's why
there's a guy next oh yeah yeah he's in
the light
can I get one of these without the other
new to sing
what was that noise Jude I can't see
even me I don't know what that was is he
even a worth taking out he's fairly
close to that other than yeah I mean you
want to worry about it right now I don't
think
oh okay oh wow a bunch of guys there's
an another dude I'm will further down
how you got there yikes
that was probably who you heard yeah
I don't want to go that way
that's hairy people on this yeah
hold r2 I think oh that was the hand
gesture I kept the prompt well that not
if you tap it yeah you knock him out I
think you can hold it
chuckle man I'll get up up I should have
[ __ ] saved this dude up there for it
there's a guy coming towards you Bridge
I think
just the rats to target that rat
do it boss these lights sketching me out
no that's dumb
yeah make sure there's no one I'm good
I really don't like these lights here my
lights
I want to say whenever you look back at
some of these guys like the prompt the
triangle like drops as if they're
getting up is I don't know seeing then
seeing things
just seems like a bug or something
you're in the thick of it now though yep
well right there he might be good uh let
me get a bet I don't know anybody's
gonna see me be that know where I am
he's knocked out he's really close to
someone else unless he's gonna
watchtower
uh-oh he's right across the street man I
think you're good
really yeah I feel like he's being
blocked by the building well you could
you could take I'll see what their
positions will do you jump this barbed
wire I think yeah I forgot about
interrogating I should have done it to
one of the guys in the watchtowers watch
he's gonna here's what you do he looked
naked from the waist down
yeah so he's gonna round see if this guy
leaves I guess yeah no you're he's gonna
turn around you're right yeah yeah I
just gotta make sure I get the right I
think it's hold are to someone season if
I was more confident could tranq that
dude and then grab him turn around 31
meters
ah I'll get him in a second dude he's
not moving I know maybe I should just
move out and try to get something else
yes yes yes yes chef do I wait for him
to come back here go get him now
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] nope nope nope nope I
mean he could turn around yeah yeah
I mean I wouldn't even bushes bushes
which one is interrogate at one table
one wait did he give ya a year didn't he
just he just said she's in a cage inside
I kept him alive just for the record
okay
if
[ __ ]
okay um there's a guy in that watchtower
he's not gonna be he's not sleeping he's
just just for good measure I'm gonna do
that I know in here no no that
watchtowers really annoying me I'm gonna
get this guy I think
it's not gonna hear their car coming I
think it was just the rain on the canopy
on the tin roof yeah
right now I'm behind pretty good
who like shot the light up [ __ ] yeah
alright so pause is really that way oh
definitely an that I remember that much
and there's vents I can cry on but
there's vents to do the truck hey I did
the truck or I think I don't know I
think he just kind of infiltrator on the
side yeah no one in that tower that's
good
I don't know if I want to clear the area
more like a path back here because
there's like that tent camp down here
tickle here we're gonna drop them no no
yeah I don't even know if I can make
this shot without
Oh
going up the watchtower give me more
better idea I think they'll see each
other drop
back here
yeah come from the other side
so oh man oh you had a mention for here
did he come over to army where wasn't
he's right down there there was two
though oh there's three three but
where's the third one right there oh why
didn't see the first guy way up there
underneath can't be okay okay why would
I go that way there's maybe over there
around I stay low enough what's your
hard right like it could use you can
kind of walk around that area yeah I can
then take out that guy at the forty for
me yeah I'm just thinking about like on
my way out I probably should just bring
her it might be tough to bring her back
to the cave that's kind of far across
there is an extraction point past the
cave oh I can't do that because hey guns
that would require explosives
do I have explosives
and that's all I can take him up maybe
God what an awful way to go over there
you should be good yeah but yeah I got
that right now gonna see sincerely hope
it's worth like getting him out of there
watchtower dude is you can go after this
other guy yeah Mike on his way back
although I wonder if anyone was looking
at oh yeah he's kind of just out in the
open I drop him I think I'm good but I
don't ya know that I don't wanna have to
go out there to his body yeah he's
really in my way though
lights yeah
good spot yeah I go through skaters the
edge at the know I guess I can know if I
want you though alright no I can't walk
it off
just like coming from
looks like a decent way up yeah there's
a dude around here
that dudes gonna be annoying yeah I
expense around here okay this I could
thing I could shoot without
I loved like sidenote I love the
animations of switching between like
stances surf smooth mm-hmm
it really is he's not coming over here I
don't think with a light there's a guy
right there I see him where the vents
with the vent access well they're like
water drains yeah yeah
so probably where those caution tape
poles are I think okay yeah I think so
I remember being toward the wall all you
go for it he's alone right answer the
hair side this area this is getting
sticky definitely not leaving him there
though
actually got about 15 minutes stop okay
sorry okay
down with the rats he's knocked out
that's good it's not the time
boss remember the time we were in better
eco Scott shit-faced
where are you Oh Oh the other guy
there's another guy way down really oh
yeah oh yeah maybe I hear footsteps
ooh cameras broke okay um so that seems
promising
I think Tara get someone again to see
where she no can you shoot the camera
cameras with no consequences
mm good question I'm really not sure
yeah cameras not yeah it mom's here that
I remember trying to do my best
I don't know I kind of like it because
it's not letting me just like game the
third person
yeah that's not looking I'm good I'm
gonna get this guy though he's gonna be
a pain about these lights I think I can
get that without him hearing how far
away is he 25 I think I'm good you might
be just coincidentally was looking at
his shoes you open this gate
yeah
yeah that's a good question I don't know
about the cameras I wonder if I should
err on the side of caution or just risk
shooting it actually I don't need to
here we go
I could interrogate him do you think
yeah he goes that way yeah but where's
that other oh that's that's you can
catch him before yeah either way you can
catch him before he goes out or away
right Jesus come back come back come
back don't come this way their camera
now
something that's probably a good spot
for him huh is this foot sticking out no
yeah this guy's close
oh the [ __ ] song I didn't there's
someone I didn't mark okay um
damnit I should move him now this guy
comes over here is he above I don't know
watch out for the other guy yeah was it
a camera you think he'll come I think
you were right I think he's on the
catwalk
oh he what is seeing is that a camera
why don't you bring him back to your
other area or you can't okay thanks
damn do should I risk shooting it I mean
I can destroy it for sure I just don't
reverse Zulu - right now it would make
things a lot easier to get over there
that's real dick so that's are you
trying to go I don't know where's pause
she in that building or I'm gonna try it
oh you going there I can what what if
there's someone in this building I can't
destroy those oh shoot this guy's gonna
call her you will date so Willie will
they sit her down I think so that was
that is the guy Walker
it's like [ __ ] Chuck Liddell huh
who's coming over
oh [ __ ] find the body
this is still a good spot for them oh I
should have called it in he'd get back
up now cuz he doesn't have Z's on Oh God
I don't know you just choked him out oh
[ __ ] they're gonna get sitrep I should
have had him call them oh oh oh that
guy's Oh God
is that the building I don't know
where's possible
can't even go anywhere from here now oh
could you start a pile of bodies over
here
Oh suck someone came from that way know
where you gonna go now I hear another
camera it's right there on the right but
there could be one closer driving risk
yeah it seemed the noise seems to
reflect our electronics are top of the
line that's it that looks familiar
over there yeah so who's coming this
dude 41 meters yeah should I take him
out when he gets over here no yeah call
it in cotton so that's what I could have
done when you interrogate them you can
have him call it in I should have done
that to that dude his back was to me so
I actually could have should I leave him
there now no cameras down these dudes
though that guy it might see you
that's where I want to go that little
lost airway yeah
where'd I put him just over here I guess
yeah
we're inside I don't know yeah I should
try to that doors probably just got ammo
maybe explosives if I need him I might
be worth checking out I'm gonna go pick
that door that's how much time eight
minutes okay
oh you're right
that's it there we go will that be
useful for I mean I'm sure it'll be
useful I was hoping for like c4 or
something smoke grenade
oh no hand grenades well be useful for
turrets okay um go this way I just gotta
watch that guy in the catwalk how you
see me oh that's how okay I could take
him out right now right the other dudes
not gonna notice from down there he
might
this Poncho's way again
you got that that guy out now yeah
I'm gonna interrogate him actually he's
by himself I don't know he might just
show I don't know if he'll show me where
pauses but I'm pretty I'm fairly started
go down there into this like boiler room
I remember collectively I recall
correctly come on turn around just come
from the other way sure sorry
nope there is no other way oh you can go
up and around the catwalk yeah well he
not see me on the stairs though I don't
think so
no I can't go
oh yeah dudes down here
Oh God
he comes over here doesn't he
I think I get oh yeah oh that was dumb
got a camera now it's not late
I'd like all right so these dudes
oh [ __ ] who's this guy oh he's gonna
come back up here if I marked him oh no
no sorry yep
yeah check this [ __ ] move out watch
this no I'm just gonna wait from they
get to the top of the ramp and then
Oh God Jim you left your gun
she can't be doing that see the body
yeah well oh you gotta do it quick he's
gonna see it quick welcome to the party
sorry oh [ __ ] I think I got a I can't
remember if this keeps him down
it doesn't more than just the tapping on
Tara game anyway okay just for good
measure I'm gonna give him a little pop
and no wayna I don't think you did it
uh I mean it takes longer yeah I have
three luck it was three left oh my god I
did not realize is that limited okay
cool
just can't really do that anymore yeah
down here four minutes think okay you
know what you're right I mean I
definitely think you're getting close
dad or maybe no that's not a door it's a
button
I'm just gonna have to go melee
turn around your jamoke
is that what does that bun do I need to
turn off the lights
do it
please don't be anybody else
girl check kill him now I haven't killed
anybody yet
down low this looks familiar what's down
here or up here is that up yeah [ __ ]
maybe that's my way out camera nevermind
I think my going back the way I cleared
out is the most obvious can you go back
to the den with her mmm I don't think so
now I have to decide between I don't
know should I just finish this at this
point or save it for next time : the
thing I think you should save it from
I've been here on I mean I don't know
where it's it I think it should save
right after I comes out of this cutscene
the game will save ya like we would yeah
like there was a continue I just got a
you can't do I'll see if I can make sure
she ain't dead she going idiot
nice Sagan sweet cool you should be good
you go check the menu though is there
any other like manual saving yeah
probably
there's like settings go do or I mean it
said save but is there like yeah yeah
well I hope it's saved
oh yeah it's like there's no settings
that's rising sorry okay well that's it
sweet nice you did it
let's go way to kick off a non Zelda
episode in the meantime I will I'll kind
of do a little bit more research on
whether we should just if I should play
through the intro phantom pain and are
often that's gonna be a boring episode
of going through the hospital with the
whole I won't spoil anything but you
haven't played phantom pain but but yeah
that's an hour there I'm essentially
close to bringing her out I just got to
decide between whether to blow up the
AAA guns and call it a helicopter close
or just bring her through the whole base
to the cave where the other dudes are
like I want to get them out still he's
moving posit cancel I mean it I mean
we're done like it all
well it might save now again I don't
know yeah one of the guard just woke up
cool okay cool well thanks Mike thank
you guys for watching waited way to
survive a non Zelda episode we'll be
back next Thursday um definitely hey I
survived resin evil you did that's true
I wasn't insinuating that you weren't
able to I still just it's just it's just
good that we didn't die cuz I don't want
to play in alien isolation at all he's
stalling okay sweet well yeah we'll be
back next Thursday we sure well thank
you guys for watching have a great rest
your week see you guys bye back
you